[Music]
[Applause]
tim callashaw he's got sources because
he's a journalist dallas morning news
columnist and of course the star of
around the horn you want to get in on
this um over under first quarterback
selected at 13 and a half
so
okay so
uh paulie has the under he says that a
quarterback will be selected in the
first 13 picks
and he has faith in a gm making a
mistake
where do you stand
yeah i mean you think normally
even though there's only a couple that
have a shot at the first round i think
uh
somebody
somebody's going to convince themselves
yeah we know more
about
you know kenny pickett or whoever than
than others and we're he's our guy i
can't imagine
13 is a long way to go i take the other
i take the under
do you uh did you have a quarterback you
fell in love with and he turned out to
be a bust
i was i was i was pretty big
excuse me i was pretty big on the drew
henson bandwagon
and i'm i'm gonna have to say that
how did that work out how did that work
out tim
that bandwagon lasted for one half of
the bears thanksgiving game
and
and bill parcells
uh
took the keys
out of the ignition
and he was never seen again see that's
why when you hear it
you hear about these mock drafts tim and
you know they everybody missed on tom
brady
yes everybody
right
so and that's yeah i mean nobody knows
they make so many mistakes
at quarterback you see the guy i mean i
was a big josh rosen guy everybody was
gil brandt troy eggman they were all big
josh rosen guys
he's been on what four teams now
i mean he just travels from team to team
um it's it's hard i don't i don't know
why quarterbacks
are so hard uh we had people
back in my radio days uh when the when
that press got strapped
two or three prominent people saying
that prescott is you know there's i
wouldn't even take him in the fourth
round
and then he did what he did so it's it's
just
it's just weird
yeah
and and i i always wonder the degree of
difficulty of making it as a quarterback
in the nfl but making it as a cowboy
quarterback because there's so much more
that goes along with that territory and
here you have tony romo and you have dak
prescott these weren't highly thought of
quarterbacks but they didn't they did
succeed or they have succeeded and you
know being there with jerry jones the
pressure of trying to win another super
bowl
um you know that that adds to the degree
of difficulty there's no other place
uh in the nfl where you have that i
don't think so and and i think it's
it's not just because it's uh this
massive america's team franchise but
it's
exacerbated by the 26 years without an
nfc championship game it has been a long
time since this team has done anything
worth really worth mentioning and so
every quarterback are you going to be
the guy
now dax got his contract is he going to
be the guy are they going to do it this
year the opportunity seems to be there
but but who knows
yeah i wonder about that uh if you start
to look at the injuries they pile up and
here's dak with non-throwing shoulder
and i know it's minor surgery but it's
another surgery
he went forever
he went through mississippi state with
really one minor injury and he played
four years so he played a long
time he's not one of these guys who
played a year or two in college he
played a long time
no injuries five years in dallas no
injuries
and then uh season six
you know you know breaks breaks the
ankle
has this shoulder injury in camp
throwing shoulder has a non-throwing
shoulder surgery now and you're saying
well oh gosh he's
he's
he's brittle he's falling apart right in
front of our eyes i mean i don't think
that's happening but
i think players get a little nervous
when
when they've gone that long without
anything
and all of a sudden stuff starts piling
up a little bit
and we always wonder about this when a
quarterback gets paid that means
somebody else doesn't get paid and you
start to look at the cowboys now i don't
know if this is going to cost them amari
cooper i don't know do you stay with
zeke elliott um what are some of the
moves that you can see for a team that's
over the salary cap
well the two that are getting talked
about and stephen jones sort of
addressed
and that i'm writing about for your
sunday paper which i hope you'll i hope
you'll buy of course i have a
subscription yes i yeah that's why they
asked me to send me my column earlier
this morning
um
are amari cooper and demarcus lawrence
they're the ones that they can get out
of the contract
amari they save i think 16 million
against ken but but these are two of
their better players i know why are they
talking about doing this
at a time
when tom brady just retired aaron
rodgers might be leaving green bay
the rams are going to have all kinds of
issues moving forward with their roster
the cowboys are 12 and 5. why they
they always want to back up the truck
they always want to be cautious now they
did this after dak and zeke's rookie
year oh
we're 13 and three let's let's get rid
of the entire secondary and start over
there
i mean so
i i don't know they could get i think
it's foolish to get rid of either one of
them you can move money around with some
contracts
and and and without just you know
crippling your future that but they
become this very frugal
spending team
not taking risks and that's not how they
not how they started not how they won
their last championship many many moons
ago
and you start to look at that division i
mean you just mentioned all the reasons
why now it's the cowboys
turn it's their time it should be
if you start to handicap the nfc
and you know you go back to that home
loss
uh you know you
start the playoffs i mean
you just wonder if uh
you know i think the eagles aren't
coming and if they do things right
they'll be there quickly they make three
picks
before the cowboys make their first pick
if a couple of those guys are playing as
rookies if if if hertz and and
you know devonte smith and some of their
offensive players are
moving forward
i don't know that dallas is much ahead
of them i don't know about the
commanders and who is going to be their
quarterback
they they but there are some people out
there and if they
i still don't know why exactly why
washington's defense
went from great dear before to god awful
yeah uh but i would think with chase
young back and others back they could
they could pick it back up but you're
right dallas has a year here they're
still better than all those teams for at
least another year with their roster do
something with that capitalize on that
don't start worrying about 2024
and and that's what they tend to do he's
tim calashawn down this morning news
columnist espn around the horn
contributor how much in advance do you
get the topics for around the horn
you know those are right off the top of
our heads sir you know we don't hear
about it
review
[Music]
um
there might be an email that goes out
uh and there might be a conference call
at 9 30 central time
on show days
that some of the people show up for
and
even i show up for it occasionally
so yes and and we
sometimes will say yeah we don't like
this one as much we like that one and
things get moved around a little but in
general
uh
uh the great aaron solomon and josh bard
mostly have that show with a little help
from tony have that show
laid out when we
when we hit the hit the floor in the
morning
have you ever gotten legitimately mad or
people have gotten legitimately mad at
one another on around the horn
well there was one person who used to
get legitimately mad a lot oh jay
mariani i i didn't say any names i'm
just saying
there was one person who used to get mad
a lot who isn't on the program um
you do it a little way you do and then
you and then you back off you go what am
i doing
like you know i didn't get enough
points for that
so i'm not gonna go down so i have to
just sit here instead of talking some
more and we're all getting paid the same
so you're not going to get too mad
there's occasionally
you think you throw out a good line and
the host
has somebody in his ear and he's not
really listening to you it's like tony
how did you miss that
i'm giving you
quality good fellas lines here and
you're not even paying attention but for
the most part
um it's a pretty
likable amiable group at this point but
if there was a fight
i could who's coming out who's coming
out of the octagon
who's coming out
sarah spain
oh
i think sarah spain might be able to
take you
i don't have any doubt about it
i am going to be
uh
you know
doing the rope-a-dope there
um
it's going to be sarah and it uh
the other one might be
uh might be a surprise it might be uh
it might be sedano
how about that oh okay
okay um you know i i don't think it's
gonna be woody or plasti or bob i think
we're past not past
our prime or anything just past the
fighting stage no no no you're right
you're past your prime
yeah no if i was why would i be the
featured tim on this
warm-up
who's had a better career you or tim
legler
um
[Laughter]
let's see
he can go out there and make like 98 out
of 100 free throws when he wakes up
that's that's impressive
and i know he can do that uh i guess
legler has
has just a slight edge but but you know
there's others that would disagree with
that keep your head up okay
i'm going to try
how are my mavericks by the way since
you guys uh chip christopher porzingis
out of town mention the good team in
town
uh luke has been on fire
uh which is not new but kind of a new
level of fire
um
you know it's gonna be interesting to
see
can they they haven't won a playoff game
as you may know since 2011 since they
beat the heat for the title most teams
don't follow up a championship by not
winning a playoff series for 10 years
and they have done that so there is a
bit of an urgency to okay
can you beat utah can you beat memphis
um and i don't know they have a
different kind of team now without
you know without porzingis and they got
a lot of point guards
and they're going to run a lot of point
guards at you and they do play defense
they play some very good defense in
stretches and that will be interesting
to see in the playoffs
yeah watching luca against lebron the
other night
and
luca was inviting lebron to guard him
he won who watched that game thinking
luca whatever he wants to is going to
get the mavericks back under control of
this game
yes
like the lakers made this run and okay
they're back in the game okay they got a
lead
but you just kind of feel like okay luke
is going to do whatever he wants it's
lakers
and lebron doesn't have the support to
be able to do everything he wants to do
against anybody
but do you i i wonder about that luca
got fat shamed or conditioned shamed to
start this year how did that play loc
locally and and i think he's addressed
it that finally addressed it like yeah
you know i think it kind of helped me
and i think he i think he
he certainly took it publicly the right
way and and while privately
he did get in better shape but he seemed
to acknowledge he wasn't in as good of
shape as he should have been
uh at the start of the year
after
olympic stuff and other stuff in the off
season but
i mean he's in his best shape now and
he's really
it's really not i mean he just
people i don't think people get that he
just turned 23 and how few players do
that much
three all-star games and all the
different things he's done
before turning 23.
when are you on around the horn again
uh danny i've done my two shows this
week i did not collect the victory
uh did not even make a showdown i don't
believe wow so
we're going to regroup over the weekend
um i'm eligible for shows monday and
tuesday
wednesday i'm going to
for the first time in 20 years i'm going
to kansas city for the big 12 tournament
i'm going to go see a little big 12
hoops
see some of those fine teams baylor and
tech from kansas
texas
even tcu beating top 10 teams so it'll
be monday or tuesday
all right well like you know i'm always
rooting for you whenever you're on
the text messages after the victories
the flowers yeah
you're always welcome
thank you tim
sauce
sauce
sauce
that's tim calashan dallas morning news
columnist espn around the horn
contributor